welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season 2 has presented a
cryptic backstory between Kang variant
he who remains and ren Slayer that seems
to pave the road toward Deadpool 3
Avengers King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars but has the war ahead
already been fought in the past in this
video I'm going to explain how the long
ago multiversal War referenced on Loki
is the same war that will soon be fought
and lost by The Avengers in Kang Dynasty
and now we are already beginning to see
the pieces being laid for Secret Wars
and battle world in the TBA the season
of Loki and I think the key to all of it
is the character of raana Ren Slayer
these Clues actually begin to present
themselves in the most mysterious moment
from episode one you are quite a Marvel
I will be proud to lead with you you
made a difference in this war thank you
for being on my team Loki then rewinds
the tape to a few seconds earlier for us
for all time always propeller rley you
are quite a Marvel I will be proud to
lead with you this recording is evidence
that he remains needed Ren Slayer to win
this multiversal war the war that Miss
minut referred to in the very first
episode of the series long ago there was
a vast multiversal War countless unique
timelines battled each other for
Supremacy nearly resulting in the total
Destruction of well everything he
remains shed more light on this war in
the season 1 finale the peace between
realities erupted into allout war each
variant fighting to preserve their
universe and
annihilate the others this is almost the
end ladies and gentlemen of everything
and everyone he remains went on to say
that the first variant encountered a
creature created from all the tears and
reality capable of consuming time and
space itself that beast's name is elith
I
weaponized elith and I ended I ended the
multiversal war once I isolated our
timeline all I had to do was manage to
to flow of time and prevent any further
branches hence the TVA now we can look
back at that pause in the middle of a
sentence I ended I ended the multiversal
war as a bit of covered up guilt from he
remains peeking through his words
because he knows that he didn't do it
alone he knows he needed renair to do
this but something went down between
them in which he downgraded her to a TVA
judge denying her the opportunity to co-
rule the TVA alongside him there are
some interesting details on this screen
beside the audio recording that we
really need to take a closer look at
because since the breakdown we were able
to clear all this up from the crap
resolution Disney plus stream to a nice
Crystal Clear 4K version now at the top
of that screen it does indeed read
temporal audio chronometer which tells
us that this is some kind of machine
that can extract audio from a specific
moment in time in fact back in the
present day version of the same room the
same device they are using it to
pinpoint a specific specific thing that
Loki said in season 1 episode 4 so
that's what this device does it zips
through all of time and space to
everything everyone has said everywhere
at all times and pinpoints an exact
sound bite of what they say and this
device categorizes every single one of
those sound bites with a specific event
number on this screen beside the word
temporal audio chronometer you see event
and right next to it the number is
listed 456 389 32- 431 and this is the
same event number at the bottom of the
screen which also lists date 0612 23 21
and beside that 18 colon 34 colon 54
which I'm wondering could refer to the
time of day like 18 3454 or 6:34 p.m.
and 54 seconds uh those numbers could
also refer to the vector but I think the
word Vector is linked with the word in
the bottom far right unknown as in they
don't know where exactly it was the
geographical location is a mystery or at
least something that this machine could
not ascertain Autumn is officially here
which means it's officially cozy season
which means it's time to start figuring
out how to find the perfect wine for
whatever spooky movie you're watching
this week and the easiest way to do that
is bright sellers look wine is not
supposed to be intimidating or confusing
or overwhelming it's meant to just be a
nice experience to share with a friend
but bright sellers makes wine easy again
all you do is you take a quiz of what
kind of wine you like and then bright
sellers will send you a couple bottles
that it thinks are right up your alley
once you try them you can leave feedback
to help bright sellers dial in what wine
is perfect for you so let's see this
week I Got King Royale it's a red blend
understated lightly chewy and dry with
notes of Plum cinnamon almond and cocoa
ooh I think it's going to be a perfect
pairing for ParaNorman or Coraline M as
an oy stop motion finish so if you want
to have some good wine let bright
sellers make it easy for you thanks
bright sellers for giving my followers
their first six bottle subscription box
usually $150 or more for just $55 so
click the link in the description or
scan the QR code in the corner to take a
quiz and to get started today now on the
right side of the screen six timelines
are listed with those same six repeated
beneath we see AGD timeline CT G29
timeline AF cg3 timeline vd2 timeline K2
e32 timeline and F fr3 timeline and of
all of these e32 timeline is highlighted
so I am going to assume that the date
this was recorded was 0612 2321 or June
12 2321 not December 6th 2321 sorry UK
folks who put the day before the month
you are right it makes more sense to do
it that way but the good old American
month before day is how the TVA listed
dates in season 1 that's probably why
Miss minutes has a Southern accent but
event number 456 389 32- 431 must be the
log of this specific moment in time and
the reasons categorized as an event
might be because it's when he remains
made the decision to alter things so
that Ren Slayer wouldn't remember this
conversation now the year 23 321 would
not apply to within the TVA the TVA
exists outside of the Gregorian calendar
timeline of our world the TVA does have
its own internal timeline axis we are
learning but 2321 would be a year from
the sacred timeline and it would imply
that the war that he remains a r Slayer
just got finished fighting that they're
talking about takes place 300 years in
the future from right now so the
multiversal war is a future War it has
not happened yet now how would that make
sense if it was long ago well as I
explained in Saturday's video time is a
flat circle it Loops back on itself so
this multiversal war is both in the
future and in the past now he remains
called Ren slay quite a Marvel and
thanked her for being on his team this I
believe tells us that the multiversal
war will take place between kangs and
that Ren Slayer was the differen maker
who chose one Kang variant whose team to
be on and that is what tipped the scales
and since he remains said it was elith
that made the difference there I think
we can speculate that it wasn't this
Kang variant alone who tamed elith that
he needed Ren Slayer to tame elith and
isn't it interesting that in the void
episode season 1 episode 5 it was Loki
and Sylvie together joining hands that
managed to tame this Beast there is a
shot from season 2 trailer footage that
shows R Slayer back in the void of the
TVA facing a purple storm based on the
lighting of the shot I think she is
staring down elith here so this does
seem to be a question this season of
Loki might answer in the full season 1
analysis I did over on the Deep dive
Channel my unifying the for he who
remains planned why he activated this
Loki variant to connect with Sylvie why
he cries in that moment if you look
closely when Loki tells silby that he
just wants her to be okay is that he
remains and all kangs are lonely they do
not have multiversal dance Partners
actually shout out to pton dver in the
comments of her breakdown for pitching
the theory that R Slayer could be Kang's
variant the Sylvie to his Loki what Loki
wanted to do rule the TVA with Sylvie
hand inand with him is what he remains
refused to do with renl so if the rumors
are true that Deadpool 3 will feature ma
mcfan as a TVA agent assigned to Loki
and Wolverine and if we do see fights
that are actually in the void in that
movie as some set photos seem to
indicate that could set up the TVA in
the MCU as a kind of multiversal Customs
Agency for all incoming heroes and
villains from other universes who arrive
to fight in secret Wars but if Kang
Dynasty shows us the multiversal war
that he remains needed rer to win as
that dog pile would be the most logical
moment in all Kang's lives for The
Avengers to Target will Ren Slayer join
he remains team on this upcoming cycle
what could The Avengers say to convince
this Marvel to make a different Choice
subscribe to all three channels in the
new rockstars Network you can follow me
at eaos follow new Rockstar subscribe to
new Rockstar for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
y'all